bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin pour débattre
des défis de l'union européenne puisque
ursula von der leyen va prononcé son
fameux discours sur l'état de l'union
première question pour vous gilles
lebreton peut-être ursula von der leyen
va se félicite évidemment de la gestion
de sa kristen de la crise sanitaire quel
est votre votre sentiment
oui bonjour bien certainement elle va se
féliciter de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par par l'union et moi mon
sentiment c'est que alors à tort de le
faire parce que il ya eu beaucoup de
ratés dans cette gestion
d'abord on a tardé à fermer les
frontières ce qui aurait contribué au
départ à éviter la propagation de la
maladie ensuite dans un deuxième temps
on a perdu beaucoup de temps à faire
acheminer des masques et puis enfin la
politique vaccinale ensuite a été une
catastrophe puisque les contrats en
particulier signé par l'union européenne
ont été très mal conçus avec des clauses
d'exonération de responsabilité pour les
laboratoires que je condamne en tant que
juriste nathalie griesbeck même question
pour vous quelle leçon doit à doit tirer
l'union européenne de ces ratés
pour ma part je pense pas qu'il y ait
exclusivement un bilan négatif a
adressé après ces terribles mois de
pandémie qui ce qu'ils sont des mois de
pandémie dans le monde entier je pense
qu'il ya eu effectivement des retards à
l'allumage mais au final aujourd'hui
sans préjuger de ce que va être la
présidente de la commission elle pourra
quand même
imprimer le fait qu'il y a je crois plus
de 70 %
d'européens qui ont été vaccinés et qu'
il y à une prise de conscience de la
nécessité de restaurer une souveraineté
au moins européenne en termes de
production et d'acheminement de
médicaments
gilles lebreton
d'avoir une souveraineté et c'est
effectivement ce que veut faire l'europe
une europe de la santé c'est possible il
faut tout fait pour mettre cela en
oeuvre
l'expérience redoutable que nous avons
connues sur l'ensemble dans l'ensemble
de la planète nous tous à le faire et
moi je ne suis pas de la même
sensibilité que cela van der leyen mais
j'apprécie chez elle son envie d'avancer
de d'agir et avec notamment le
commissaire thierry breton de prendre
les mesures pour commencer à
aller vers une souveraineté parce que la
santé c'est un élément déterminant pour
pour tous et bien entendu pour les
européens il vous aura pas échappé non
plus que je pense qu'elle va sans doute
en parler que l'europe aussi prend des
dispositions à travers les systèmes
kovacs pour apporter son aide à d'autres
à des pays tiers de façon à ce que nous
puissions juguler ensemble plus le mieux
possible cette pandémie c'est long à
mettre en place ah oui mais c'est ça la
était simple partout et est ce que
quelqu'un peut citer un état ou un
peuple qui ait eu aucune difficulté à
trouver les pare-feu par rapport à cette
pandémie
redoutable
qui se métamorphose on le voit avec les
différents variant donc c'est très
facile depuis son ordinateur de porter
des jugements à l'emporte-pièce c'est
autre chose d'accueillir d'agir ensemble
de le faire de matières manière
coordonnée et j'ai souvenir petit breton
a vraiment pris le taureau par les
cornes comme on dit dans l'adage
français pourquoi pour mettre en oeuvre
les dispositifs permettant à la fois de
produire des vaccins avec il ya eu des
ratés ensuite et d'ailleurs les choses
avancent de ce côté là par rapport donc
aux laboratoires qui n'aurait pas était
honnête dans dans les dents les négocier
pardon dans les livraisons oui
effectivement je suis bien sûr il faut
d'ailleurs se tenir compte des échecs de
l'expérience pour pouvoir avancer
agirait et servir les peuples et donc il
ya aussi un défi parce que coûte l
instant
les micro trottoirs il ya aussi un défi
d'explication et de communication de la
part de laurent g à cet égard la
présidente trois essais de la plus
transparente possible par rapport à
l'action de l'europe et qui est toujours
trop peu lisible alors effectivement sol
avant de ryan devrait se féliciter
d'avoir 70 % de vacciner en europe alors
les experts mettent un peu en doute ce
chiffre il parle plutôt de 57 7%
vacciner au 31 août
même les instances européennes le
reconnaissent vous disiez personne n'a
su faire mieux alors il ya la grande
bretagne a quand même réussi à avoir des
vaccins très très rapidement la preuve
peut-être qu'on réussit mieux au niveau
local gilles lebreton que j'imagine oui
alors tout à fait en matière de santé
d'ailleurs je tiens à rappeler que la
santé est une compétence des états
d'après les traités européens dans moi
je suis extrêmement choqué de voir la
facilité avec laquelle on laisse la
commission de bruxelles s'emparer d'une
compétence qui est une compétence
étatique moi je pense que la santé doit
être gérés par chaque état ça n'exclut
pas évidemment une certaine solidarité
les états les plus avancées peuvent
aider les états à les moins avancés
doivent le faire d'ailleurs mais on n'a
pas besoin d'un système bureaucratique
centralisé à bruxelles pour y arriver je
crois que là en est en pleine dérive
fédéraliste et moi j'en fais un cheval
de bataille je j'affirme avec mon parti
politique le rassemblement national que
la santé doit rester une compétence
nationale
nathalie griesbeck crée une haute
autorité pour la santé rajouter encore
un échelon supplémentaire alors qu'on
l'a vu même les ars était contesté
pendant la crise est-ce que va pas
compliquer les choses et qui en aura la
gouvernance surtout
au créneau pour avoir une coordination
notamment de la production de
l'acheminement des dés de certains
médicaments dont on s'est aperçu et il
était grand temps de le faire que nous
avions de très grandes difficultés à
pouvoir pour voir en fait aux besoins
des européens est une excellente idée
c'est pas parce qu'il y a une structure
de coordination que ça empêche les états
membres de garder leur politique de
santé c'est une façon un peu hypocrite
camo qu'à mon ex-collègue parce qu'on
était collègues un moment donné de
d'expliquer qu' on serait dans une forme
de fédéralisme
si seulement de mon point de vue nous
avions un certain sur certains thèmes la
possibilité de le faire d'avoir une très
forte coopération très forte
coordination
c'est une excellente chose sans l'europe
nous n'aurions pas réussi à avoir la
production de vaccins de vaccins et la
recherche ça n'a pas été évoquée mais ça
tombe sous le sens également donc il est
un peu facile de tordre le cou à des
idées 1 enfin ou d'avancer des idées
très simple et d'oublier tordre le cou à
un monceau de préjugés avoir une haute
autorité qui coordonne qui coopèrent qui
organise c'est une excellente chose au
niveau du demi milliard de citoyens que
nous constituons et du regard que ceux
ci peuvent apporter à l'extérieur
puisque c'est endémie ne connaît pas de
frontières
lll concerne moi qu'il vit dans un
territoire absolument frontaliers ou
quatre cent mille personnes tous les
matins
travail au luxembourg et rentre le soir
vous imaginez bien que fermer les
frontières en disant oh là là on va
arrêter la pandémie c'est une absurdité
donc avoir des instances qui coordonne
et qui coopèrent entre elles pour
apporter les réponses aux besoins des
citoyens en europe est une excellente
chose ça n'enlève en rien la compétence
de principe des états en matière de
santé on va parler d'afghanistan
également gilles lebreton puisque la
commissaire devrait également en parler
tirer les leçons de ce retrait quelque
peu chaotique relancer une europe de la
défense ça vous paraît faisable
mais n'ont pas davantage que la santé la
défense est aussi une compétence
nationale d'après les traités européens
enfin il faudrait quand même respecter
ces traités européens
nous on nous accuse constamment de
vouloir combattre l'union européenne
mais nous nous voulons déjà qu'on
respecte les traités européens existants
et qu'on n'aille pas au delà ce serait
déjà un premier pas intéressant moi pour
moi la défense doit rester nationale
parce que chaque état a évidemment ses
propres intérêts stratégiques qui ne
sont pas nécessairement les mêmes que
ceux de ses voisins donc cette europe de
la défense n'a selon moi absolument est
rigoureusement aucun sens et
particulièrement dans le cas de la
france qui est une puissance nucléaire
qui est une puissance il est rare
puissance dans ce monde à pouvoir
exporter ses armées pour aller maintenir
l'ordre la paix ailleurs et donc nous
avons moins encore que nos voisins
besoin de cette de cette illusion d'une
armée européenne et puisque vous me
parler d'art réaliste ans je tiens à
vous dire que pour moi l'art ganis temps
à court terme ne pose pas des problèmes
de défense mais des problèmes évidemment
de migration alors je ne fais pas
référence aux quelques arguant qu'ils
ont travaillé pour la france et que l'on
aura patrice c'est tout à fait normal il
faut les récompenser de leur fidélité
mais je fais je fais référence aux
dizaines et peut-être un mot centaines
de milliers d'afghans qui vont bientôt
fuir leur pays et
il faut trouver les solutions
internationales mais pour moi c'est
solution ne consiste pas à ouvrir en
grand les frontières de l'union
européenne parce que on le sent très
bien on a déjà de grandes difficultés à
intégrer les flux de migrants qui sont
arrivés et d'ailleurs on le voit
strasbourg puisque mon propre hôtel a
été réquisitionné pour y loger 150
afghans donc un moment donné il faut
quand même rappeler la formule de michel
rocard la france ne peut pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde
non pas politique d'immigration nathalie
griesbeck les les leçons à tirer de
l'afghanistan effectivement avec
l'injonction aux pays européens
d'accueillir ses avants qui fuit
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans
comment est ce que l'europe doit prendre
en compte cette question bat michel
rocard la france ne peut pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde mais elle doit
apporter y apporter sa part et peut-être
une réponse plus dur c'est la situation
en afghanistan
qui était imprévisible à ce point en ce
qui concerne le départ des américains
qui a été absolument catastrophique
pose question l ensemble du monde et
comme d'habitude en termes de diplomatie
internationale
l'europe n'est pas la seule concernée
par la part par les problèmes que vous
reconnaitre les afghans à partir de
maintenant alors qu'ils ont des crises
ont eu une période de deux 2 calme et
donc
je pense que nous avons à travailler la
france n'a pas n'a pas dit qu'elle
allait accueillir tous les afghans quel
une politique de quotas en place comme
ça avait déjà été le cas
c'est un budget
extrêmement difficile puisqu'il faut
trouver des alliés il faut trouver un
système moi j'appelle de mes voeux
depuis enfin lorsque j'étais pendant une
quinzaine d'années au parlement européen
notamment dans la commission des
libertés
la justice et des affaires intérieures
une organisation commune un accord entre
les états membres pour avoir une
politique migratoire qui soit cohérente
et qui correspondent aux besoins
d'aidé européen et pour cela il faut
trouver un accord je
les vôtres je suis assez d'accord sur le
fait que nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui
à l'ouverture d'une défense européenne
où nous sommes
tout à fait d'accord et je pense que
nous sommes pas les deux seuls à l'être
mais
prendre conscience que la france par
exemple qui lorsque le royaume uni et
eve dans l'union européenne étaient les
seuls états au fonds à apporter donc une
présence militaire une aide militaire un
accompagnement militaire est aujourd'hui
quasiment deux salles c'est une question
qui se pose à l'ensemble des européens
et du toit doit être travaillé alors
voir aujourd'hui sous la forme d'une
défense européenne nous ne sommes
absolument pas là en revanche vous allez
dire que c'est une obsession sur la
coopération la coordination
imaginer d'avoir une politique
industrielle en termes d'armement qui
soit plus cohérent contre les états
membres c'est pas du tout absurde et ça
répond par ailleurs sans doute aux
attentes des européens on en n'est pas
une défense européenne en revanche les
questions de migration et de sécurité je
me suis beaucoup plus léger on va on
continue d'en parler parce que justement
l'ancien commissaire européen michel
barnier a lui même était très critique
sur la question migratoire pour l'ancien
négociateur du brésil je cite il faut
retrouver une souveraineté juridique sur
la question des migrations regardez
nous ne pouvons pas faire tout cela sans
avoir retrouvé notre souveraineté
juridique en étant menacée en permanence
d'un arrêt ou d'une condamnation de la
cour de justice européenne ou de la
convention des droits de l'homme ou
d'une interprétation de notre propre
institution judiciaire
gilles lebreton il conteste clairement
la primauté du droit européen sur les
droits nationaux est ce qu il a raison
michel barnier
mais écoutez oui bien sûr il a raison et
nous c'est ce que nous disons depuis
bien des années et je me réjouis de voir
que michel barnier se rend compte que
nous avions raison en matière de
d'immigration sur tous les grands sujets
régaliens dont le thème des migrations
fait partie il faut absolument que la
france retrouve sa souveraineté et il
faut réaffirmer dans les termes les plus
clairs que dans la hiérarchie des normes
la constitution française est au dessus
de tous les traités internationaux même
des traités de l'union européenne est ce
que je vous dis là d'ailleurs n'est pas
du tout une pensée révolutionnaire
puisque c'est ce qu'a rappelé encore il
ya quelques mois le conseil d'état dans
un arrêt french data network il a repris
exactement les propos que je viens de
tenir c'est à dire que la constitution
française est au sommet de la hiérarchie
des normes et même aux deux fils droit
de l'union européenne et dont il faut en
tirer les conséquences quand des
intérêts vitaux de la france sont en jeu
eh bien il faut s'appuyer sur cette
hiérarchie des normes pour imposer nos
décisions même aux instances européennes
donc michel barnier ne fait que répéter
ce que nous disons depuis longtemps et
ne fait que répéter ce qui correspond à
notre ordre juridique français nathalie
griesbeck comment était perçue les
propos de michel barnier au niveau
européen
moi j'étais très étonnée je me suis dit
que michel barnier avait peut-être eu un
petit mal d'altitude
puisque c'est un montagnard et ça peut
arriver en disant que c'était vraiment
que sur les questions d'immigration
oui mais
j'ai suivi évidemment comme tous les
européens et en tant que parlementaire
très attentivement les travaux qu'il a
menée sur le break site
dont on voit parfois encore les et c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire les lacunes
et
elle et les difficultés mais là je veux
dire qu'il pas beaucoup beaucoup étonné
de sa position assez saugrenue alors
pour pour
analyser comme mon plan de jeu les dix
comme vient de le faire mon collègue qui
est jury se croit d'ailleurs il me
semble je crois que vous êtes juriste un
comme moi
on peut palabres et on peut on peut
faire des discours de trottoirs mais il
n'y a qu'une chose qui compte c'est dans
ce cas-là changer les traités j'ai pas
d'autre solution là c'est pas parce que
le conseil d'état est la plus haute
juridiction administrative française
prend une position dans une
jurisprudence que ça renverse la
situation il suffit pas de sauter en
disant comme un cabri je veux je veux
que pour une seule thématique on ne
respecte plus les décisions de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme houda
cour de justice de l'union européenne
que ça se fait c'est tout c'est un
mécanisme de changement fondamental des
traités et ensuite de toute
jurisprudence qui s'ensuit mais je suis
reprise en matière d'immigration des
d'accord ou pas tête michel barnier
avait une envie de flatter l'électorat
d'extrême droite c'est très possible et
c'est très étonnant et sur la
souveraineté retrouvée de la france en
matière d'immigration vous seriez
d'accord
c'est à moi que ça ce bien sûr oui oui
bien sûr je crois que la question des
migrations vous suivez hier très
attentivement des départs j'essaie de
les élections législatives en allemagne
et qui sont qui ont lieu dans une
dizaine de jours à présent et qui
d'ailleurs sont des conditions
stratégiques je ne sais pas où cela
retarde la n va pas à les évoquer mais
c'est quelque chose d'important par
rapport aux équilibres des années à
venir de voir comment le franco-allemand
travaillera et bien la question des
migrations elle est encore ni débat
parce que les allemands chaque année ont
besoin de 400 mille
migrants émigré pour faire fonctionner
leurs économies donc là les questions à
se poser tous les états membres encore
une fois c'est avec au cas par cas comme
le l'a souvent dit le chef de l'état
français au cas par cas une intégration
est donc une chance donnée à des
non-européens pour pouvoir vivre et
travailler au service de l'économie
européenne dans un bon climat s'agisse
d'actes malheureusement on n'a plus le
temps vous parliez de l'économie
européenne et je voulais vous parler du
plan de relance également
malheureusement on n'en a pas le temps
merci à tous les deux en tout cas merci
gilles lebreton d'avoir participé en
direct à ce débat sur arte france